alright I'm once again for the movie a
retrospective show now as I mentioned on
the last episode of the podcast our
friend Dominic sent us the steelbook
edition of John Carpenter's assault on
precinct 13 which was on the list to
review anyway but we decided we would
get around to it so thank you very much
Dominic that was yeah really cool yeah
Dominic actually followed instructions
he sent me a damn blu-ray that steelbook
with that sounds like an awesome man
thanks yeah I actually didn't like this
movie the first time I saw it but
watching it again it's pretty it's
pretty [ __ ] cool it's one that
definitely needs like a second viewing
because yeah it's better on the second
viewing I mean I think okay so this was
John Carpenter's I guess you could call
his first real movie cuz he did make
Dark Star before this but that was I
mean let's be honest that wasn't film
yeah so this was like his first one now
the interesting thing about this is that
basically this producer comes to him and
is like you can make a movie and you can
make whatever you want as long as it's
under a hundred thousand dollars yeah
right so John Carpenter had been writing
spec scripts and one of them was this
movie although it wasn't called assault
on precinct 13 it was actually called to
the Anderson Alamo he wanted to make a
Western but obviously you're not gonna
be able to make a Western for $100,000
because you need all like the period
costumes and sets and everything your
horses right and that kind of stuff so
he said well I'll do a Western but I'll
set it in present-day
Los Angeles yeah what he did here
actually um you can really see that this
is a prototype of a lot of carpenter
movies to come oh yeah the first time I
watched it it seemed to be kind of like
a jumbled kind of mess and kind of
random at first and I think I might have
been fighting the movie I was trying to
make the movie into something that it
wasn't instead of just letting the movie
roll basically what you got here is you
have like a weird mixture of a Western
escape from New York
and the Warriors yeah kinda remember
that old [ __ ] cheesy ass gangster
movie warm out and play going to like
you know with South Side Story or with
West Side Story yeah it's going to be
hardest [ __ ] and look dressed like that
didn't work can I say just how much I
love like the gang in the Street gang in
this is called streep Thunder yes and I
I must say that I love all the names of
like gangs from the movies in the 70s
and 80s but it's like so the gangs
called Street Thunder I'm like what was
twinkle bunnies or in in the movie you
see a lot of like character archetypes
that that carpenter uses later yeah in
movies like Wilson is definitely Snake
Plissken oh yeah big time
you know Napoleon Wilson is one of the
convicts in this yeah and he's kind of
like you know he's more like a Johnny
Cash type guy he doesn't look as cool as
snake but you know had had the crustle
been around in this era which he wasn't
he was a little kid probably working for
Disney at this time yeah I think he was
still you know was around crustle would
have been cast and then there's a black
convict in there who's pretty [ __ ]
cool and you can tell that this is
basically Keith David later on had
better keep David in the thing yeah
there's a hottie in there who is kind of
like a tough secretary for the cops you
know I'm a police secretary and that
would have been Adrienne Barbeau yeah
could there's a some boob action there
too it's weird because Adrienne was like
in your face this girl is kind of like
lift and separate was like good friends
make it fun that bra the whole [ __ ]
time I wasn't her it's the bra this bra
it's like that's what's so funny it's
like the first time that she comes on
that her character name is Lea she's
actually played by Laurie Zimmer I'll
get into yes yeah yeah but it's like
it's just so funny to me how I guess
this was the thing in the early 70s
because I do remember like Playtex
commercials and stuff like that so as
Playtex that were like lift and separate
I'm like why on earth would you want to
do that
well it's like I guess it's better sway
don't point it that way
well it's better than having like a boob
shelf
essentially which
which is kind of what I have with the
weather whether I like it or not rather
have that Bhushan but for women that
were just like you know be cups or C
cups or whatever it's like for some
reason all the bras at that time we're
like yeah you have to like lift them up
which that's good but then you want them
like far apart I'm like no I don't think
we want them far apart the very
strange-looking yeah and then we both
said lift and separate at the same time
yes excuse me sorry and then like the
main characters Connor is a policeman
who's like a black lieutenant and he's
really getting kind of a shitty end of
the stick they're making him guard this
ya know right isn't he like new ones
John a new on the job like I'm rookie
but he's a lieutenant so he came out of
Academy yeah he's not really getting
much respect and they make him guard
this police precinct that that the cops
are moving out of so yeah um the very
last shift in this police station and
having nothing to do with this again
killed an ice-cream man and a little
girl and the father of the little girl
goes on a rampage and kills a couple
these gang members and he runs into that
police station the gang sees him so
later on that night they make this big
assault on this damn police station it's
like something out of a western movie
yeah it convicts out to help defend the
damn police station and they don't have
enough ammo and a lot of cool [ __ ]
happens in it for some reason it I
really wanted the movie to be escape
from New York when I was first watching
it which got in the way of the tone of
the movie you just gotta accept the
movie for what it is the Edit is a
little strange by today's standards it's
a movie of the time the dialogue is very
much dialogue of the time but it still
has that awesome soundtrack that the
score to this is scoring great yeah this
I mean all carpenters great carpenters
got this first and this is the late 70s
the 76 the 76 of mid-70s and you could
tell the score is like way ahead of its
time it was like something Bowie would
have written like off the lowest thing
about seeing this is that you can see
I mean I haven't seen Dark Star for a
really long time but you can see that
this is you know his first like real
movie it only costs like a hundred
thousand dollars to make but you can see
it's almost like john carpenter's vision
came out like fully formed you know what
i mean like the shots in this movie like
the music this is very dirty it's
carpenter arrives as carpenter he really
does it's not like he's there's kind of
this nascent I mean the thing is yes
it's a movie from 1976 yes you can tell
it's from 1976 yes and there's that kind
of tropes and it was made for cheap
although it doesn't look cheap it
actually looks really good because he
said that they spent like a large
portion of the budget on like the best
like Panavision camera is like the best
processing because they wanted it to
look like a real movie now I was living
in California at the time out a minute
probably about seven and it reminds me
of growing up in Carson California and
that era just as shitty as [ __ ]
Carson in California look everything
looks like it was everything looked like
crap in the day it's Florida kind of
looked like that - a little yeah
everything looked old before its time
weird Spanish [ __ ] cheap looking
buildings [ __ ] dead grass everywhere
[ __ ] litter I could remember it as a
kid
[ __ ] Carson was a [ __ ] ghetto yeah
you know and I'm glad I got out of there
but it kind of did so they take the
[ __ ] lower middle class [ __ ]
working-class Californian they do make
it look kind of a post-apocalyptic
without any damn input they didn't have
changing thing yeah [ __ ] area look
they yeah they shot in like a particular
neighborhood the interiors were a set
you know or like a you know I said like
on a studio but the some of the freeway
scenes and stuff like that was just like
a closed down like stretch of freeway
that was being worked on or whatever so
they actually just got to film on that
so they really got like the most bang
for their buck I guess yeah the thing
that I think the first time I saw this
cuz I think like you the first time I
saw assault on precinct 13 cuz I love
you know John Carpenter's Bob obviously
the thing escape from me or ik Halloween
and I saw this one and I was just kind
of like but watching it again I
think the first time that I watched it I
didn't connect all the [ __ ] because what
ends up happening she's destroyed it
seems just disjointed but then when you
watch it again like easily the first
half of this man it's not a long movie
it's only 91 minutes I think easily the
first half of this movie if not more is
setting up all the threads like the very
beginning and they don't even like a lot
of its show don't tell like a lot of it
they don't really say what's going on or
there's just like [ __ ] like a newscast
in the background or something like that
because I don't think that I connected
the shots at the beginning with like all
the gang members dead with the then the
four remaining gang members doing the
thing would feel like the blood oath or
whatever they were already they had
stole like a bunch of weapons and then
the cops like raided their hideout and
shot a bunch of their gang members yes
straight thunder and um and then so they
had swore a blood oath they're gonna get
back at the cops and just they're gonna
start shooting random people around LA
just because they're mad so there's that
strain that starts then you have the
whole thing with lieutenant Bishop and
he's kind of like got to go to this
[ __ ] yeah you know push things
closing down and then you have this
other [ __ ] where the four gang members
are driving around town like you know
wanting to shoot random people and then
you get like um then there's also the
thing about Wilson and his buddy the
other convict yeah and then there's like
a whole bus full magic sign of the Keith
David crustle dynamic that's happening
in the thing it's kind of like that yeah
so you can say it's not a bus full cuz
it's only like it's like six and they're
all like in a bus and they're going to
Sonora which is like a four or five hour
drive or something like that so they're
all like that and they kind of get stuck
in this precinct too because one of the
convicts is sick yet I don't know what
he has it's like [ __ ] tuberculosis or
some [ __ ] and they're afraid that it's
gonna like spread to the other convicts
on the bus and it's like we have to put
him in the corona they have to like put
him in the cells it's like until they
didn't get a doctor and then there's
this other thread with like this dad and
his daughter who were driving - I think
the implication from their conversation
was that they were going to I guess his
girlfriend's house and they're gonna
like they're all gonna move in together
or something so they were going there
and he kind of got lost
and then she ends up she's like oh I'm
hungry and he's like it was a bad
neighborhood we shouldn't stop and stuff
and then he has to stop at a phone booth
like to call the person to be like where
the [ __ ] is your house or whatever and
she sees an ice-cream truck and this is
probably the most notorious scene for
this movie because the 70s in the 80s in
the movies they did not [ __ ] around it's
like pretty much this little girl goes
to get ice cream she gets the ice cream
she walks away from the truck
but then the gang like comes up to the
truck and then they're like you know
they're beating the [ __ ] out of the ice
cream truck driver she looks and sees
she has the wrong ice cream she wanted
vanilla twist and he just gave her plain
vanilla she walks back to the truck and
blam dude plugs already heated plugs are
right in the chat and she just kills
every day now some interesting details
about the the gang members I haven't
verified this I really haven't time to
go back because I just remembered it
right now two of them look like guys
that starred in other carpenter flicks
one of them is a kind of a bearded
Latino guy with a beret kind of looks
like a che guevara but yeah and I think
that's the same guy who played Cuervo
Jones and escape from LA it might be the
other guys kind of blond hair kind of a
pug nose or you know kind of yeah he
plays white warlord that's white warlord
is his name you were mentioned in his
nose and I couldn't I couldn't stop
thinking about dudes nose he did kind of
have that upturn it's a little bit of an
upturn a little bit of upturned oh yeah
died that seems to be the same guy from
escape New York it is him yeah with the
mohawk and his fingers he passed away
not too long ago yeah he did a good job
in both of those movies he was great in
escape from New York yeah um so was the
other guy the guy played Cuervo Jones
I'm not real sure okay I don't remember
it looks to be him it probably is
because it worked with a lot of because
um Nancy Loomis is in this as well she
was in Halloween obviously later on um
she had a small part in this but the eye
it was funny because the first time we
saw this the little girl that gets shot
oh and fun fact
um when John Carpenter first submitted
this to the MPA to get a rating they
said okay well you're gonna get an X
rating unless you cut out that scene
where that little girl gets shot in the
chest cuz that's pretty hardcore yeah
and um he was like
okay so then he cut that scene out sent
that print back to the MPAA but the fern
that he sent to the theater still had a
car from dirty they did that uh
carpenter back in the 70s and early 80s
from to for me he was known as a kid
growing up watching this [ __ ] he was
known for putting cool guns in his
movies yeah like you know skate from New
York you know it was kind of highlighted
to mac-10 and snakes version of the Mack
tamatha scope on a suppressor which is
[ __ ] crazy and then like the core
burner from escape from LA and in this
one he had some pretty cool [ __ ] at
first I thought it was a mistake they
show that the show the white warlord in
the backseat of the damn assassin
vehicle that they're using he's got an
m16 81 and I'm looking and looking at
the muzzle and I'm going man the [ __ ]
fast of the flash suppressor is gone
that's a mistake
you know what the hell date you know I
was thinking that might have had
something dude the blank adapter then
the next time they show it he had a
suppressor on there so I got it right he
screwed a sound suppressor on there and
they're doing they did a lot of work
than the movie with m16s they were
suppressed I think it wasn't just one
m16 or was it multiple do you remember
Jenny no I don't remember and then so
there's m16s with suppressors on a wands
and then there's a mauser c96 broom
handles suppressed with kind of a hook
you looking suppressor on there I don't
think you could suppress a mouse or the
barrel request to the rear it's a toggle
action so well no it's not a tower
action it's no no Luger was but it might
have been a taco boxing no it's now it's
got a bolt in it like a rifle that's
right but I don't think you could
suppress that effectively with Jam
anyway just for you gun guys it does
have some pretty cool guns for the time
you look at him now and they wouldn't be
impressive but that was well the fact
that some of the guns were silencer had
suppressors on him was kind of a big
plot point because that was one of the
reasons why they could get away why they
could get away with attacking because
there wasn't that many people around in
the neighborhood so no one was really
hearing all the guns there um so like I
said is a cool idea but it's in reality
to plot hole because when you suppress
weapons of that caliber they're not
quiet it just takes well yeah but
you'd still hear they would stay would
be like instead of shooting five five
six or nine millimeters all sound like
you were shooting 38 nine millimeters an
unsuppressed 22 just quiet some down a
little bit this is a whole Hollywood
thing of that's suppressors but
silencers don't exist there they're
called suppressors and suppressors just
kind of bring the noise down to a level
where you don't really need as much
hearing protection or a rifle kind of
now sounds like a pistol but it works in
the movies because it works in in in in
movie plots so that's why they use them
well in like I said they did kind of
acknowledge that because they were
saying that there wasn't anybody around
the the neighborhood was largely
abandoned and I thought it was
firecrackers just gonna say that later
on like when the cops are driving around
looking for you know where all this [ __ ]
is happening that comes over the radio
it's like fireworks or could be gunshots
so some people did hear it okay then
that's it wasn't like completely native
said then that means carpenter must have
known ya gave himself out which is good
that's good on carpenter no I yeah so
basically even though I mean this movie
it like obviously is it's not a remake
of Rio Bravo the the John Wayne movie
from 1959 but it's a similar kind of
thing where you know in that movie where
they were all kind of like stuck in a
saloon and they were like Charlie it's
like all these gang members and stuff
also um a little bit of Night of the
Living Dead because when the gang comes
in approaches they're not it's not like
a type of thing in action movies where
there's like protagonist antagonist and
they both have like personalities the
gang is essentially like pretty faceless
and they don't talk much or anything
like that see hands coming at you
through the so it's girls and he's
saying that that's kind of like one of
the inspirations for that he did that in
Escape from New York too with the
animals that came up out of the ground
and grabbed that girl and remember that
they had a sit what I forgot what they
were called he had a name for them
scavengers or something but yeah there's
a lot of crossover yeah it's just when
you go when you see this one don't
expect escape from new york expect a
western if you take it as a western that
the tone works better yeah it's not a
sci-fi because um
you know obviously John Carpenter was a
big fan of Howard Hawks who made you
know who made Rio Bravo and he also made
thing from another world I think if I'm
not mistaken and so he used a lot of
tropes from that and especially like the
character of Lee that's played by Laurie
Zimmer she's kind of like the prototype
what they would call the Howard Hawks
woman because she was like this kind of
tough but feminine broad that was like
not taking any [ __ ] and everything
because the funny thing about her in
this movie and I've seen this as you
know kind of portrayed as both the
criticism and you know something that
people like about the movie is that she
is completely like badass and like stoic
like she gets shot like an arm like a
bullet just wings or something and she's
like does not react at all yeah and then
later she's like oh yeah my arm kind of
hurts and I can't move it but she's just
like a total badass it's like not having
it and there was like that was like a
connection between her and Wilson yeah
who was the convict guy he killed some
guys in it they never he never really
answered why he killed him but he must
have had a good reason is basically what
he said yeah cuz he seemed like a good
guy at mine he they asked you know why
she just run he wasn't the kind of guy
to run and leave people in need which
means that he must have killed a bunch
of bad guys helping somebody else and he
was willing to go to jail for it yeah
you know it was cool flick watching it a
second time I think improved it a lot
for me I don't know if it was the mood
or whatever but I think just multiple
viewings me not fighting and trying to
make it a movie that it was yeah I was
playing it and kind of wanted to see
escape from New York but that's not
carpet it wasn't at that level yet
didn't have that budget and I think like
I said on a second and third viewing
because I watched it again actually this
morning so I watched it a third time
this morning you really start to see
like I said the way all the threads that
he sets up at the beginning like all
come together this one and I think I
didn't really get that I kind of just
got like all these like it seems to be a
hodgepodge of first well yeah and
another thing that kind of ruins the
tone for me when on first viewing is
that the exterior shots of the police
and the people in the cars reminded me a
lot of like old television series like
adam-12
yeah about their uniforms and the tone
of the outside tone and it was kind of
different than the interior shots and
other shots that seemed to be kind of
like on when I first saw it seemed like
they had kind of woven two movies
together yeah
you know man but on the second viewing
it was a lot better remember some of the
exterior shots I'm doing at night where
they were shooting from outside the car
yeah and the cool angles yeah I actually
looked like something out of Mad Max to
warrior so it's pretty good but yeah
it's like there's like a lot of cool you
were actually asking about um you were
actually asking about the actress that
played Laurie Zimmer very famous very
famously she kind of hated her her
performance in this because she thought
it was like too deadpan or do
understanded or whatever even though
that's what John Carpenter told her to
do because like I said he wanted her to
be like a Howard Hawks type woman
character and the interesting thing
though is that you cuz you were asking
because you thought she looked kind of
familiar so I looked up her IMDB but
it's like she was only in really a
handful of movies and like a couple of
stage plays and then I guess her career
wasn't really going her acting career
wasn't really going the way she wanted
so 1979 she retired and she went became
a teacher so apparently she's still a
teacher nowadays also the guy that
played the guy that played a Napoleon I
think his name's Darwin Josten he was in
the fog later on I thought he looked
familiar and he was also an eraser head
you know so in the guy that played
Bishop Austin Stoker he was in a [ __ ]
ton of stuff too weirdly he usually
played villains yeah he was in three
from hell I guess I didn't recognize him
because he's like a lot older now
obviously but it's just it's interesting
how and like I said the little girl that
got shot the first time that I watched
this I was like goddammit that looks
like Holly from Land of the Lost yeah
but it wasn't because her name's Kim
Richards I recognize her she was in a
[ __ ] ton of like Disney movies in the
early 70s I recognized her from escape
from Witch Mountain that's where I had
seen her before but she was in like a
ton of those kind of Disney movies and
TV movies I Herbie the lovebug and all
that she was in light and she was in
like some TV shows and stuff like that
too in the 70s I think nowadays now that
she's I mean she's in her 50s now but I
think she's on like [ __ ] Real
Housewives of Beverly
Hills are one of those reality shows
that I don't watch that one of the
interesting things about this and before
we wrap up is that when this movie came
out oh another thing too that I didn't
realize this spec script was written
about the same time that John Carpenter
wrote one called eyes which would go on
to become eyes of Laura Mars which was
like a movie that I really loved growing
up and I didn't realize that John
Carpenter I mean it's like it's like a
film noir type
I remember the trailer as a kids yeah it
was a creepy church I don't think I ever
saw it I'd have to see it again I
haven't seen it for probably 25 years or
25 or 30 years but I remember really
liking it I was growing up but the
interesting thing about this is that
when it came out in theaters you know it
was kind of like billed as like a sort
of exploitation action movie a [ __ ] like
that um it did okay and it got like
mixed reviews and stuff in the u.s. it
would it screened at the at a London
Film Festival in 1977 they [ __ ] loved
it yeah immediately it's like the guy
that ran the Film Festival was like this
is the best movie ever everybody has to
come see it so it's like you know the
fact that it did so well in the UK
because I think that the UK audiences
seemed to recognize that it was supposed
to be a Western like right away where I
see where it seems like the US audiences
were kind of more ambivalent toward it
I'm not really sure why but because the
Brits loved it so much I feel like it
kind of got you know a sort of critical
reassessment like in the US over the
ensuing years I think of the time in 76
there were a lot of movies that were
kind of like this maybe or there was you
know there had been a lot of movies
there were a lot of westerns and
westerns was kind of a tired Jean maybe
that's why it maybe American audience
were kind of sick yeah and we're just
kind of like running there was a buck
you know there's a bunch of action
movies you know like bullet mm you know
trail you know Steve McQueen movie yes
and you know I don't really think this
kind of competed with those it kind of
got a critical reassessment there like I
said and I've seen aged well though yeah
and I've seen some people that actually
place it in their top I mean I
seeing some critics that say it's their
favorite John Carpenter movie I'd have
to say known um but I've most most
people that are into John Carpenter they
usually put it around three like behind
the thing in Halloween um I would
probably put it in the top five of John
Carpenter's movies it's hard to say you
know what I mean because you see I
didn't like escape from LA on first
viewing but after multiple viewings that
kind of grew to like escape from LA yeah
so I really kind of like the thing
Escape from New York
escape from LA to Halloween once the fog
there's a lot of good he had a lot of
good movies I think this one is at the
bottom of his good ones I would say yeah
but way above [ __ ] like ghosts of Mars
and some of those stuff some of those
movies I don't think Carpenter actually
directed I just think he's guy's name on
yeah it could be I don't think he was
totally involved in a lot of those bad
once it came out they don't just taste
don't feel like a carpenter movie
someone don't yeah like and I don't know
if that's just because he got older and
he kind of like lost his mojo or if he
wasn't as involved because I feel like
his movies he's headed friends directing
for I mean this movie particularly
assault on precinct 13 he not only wrote
and directed it he also edited it under
the name jaunty chance which was the
John Wayne character from Rio Bravo he
named himself that but he actually did
edit it and he did the score and he
produced it too I think
problem with carpenters he he came out
with some badass [ __ ] flicks and got
shat on every time see thing came out
and that was a badass flick and the
critics and he just [ __ ] on it it didn't
make enough money yeah et whipped its
ass and then it was the same thing with
uh Escape from New York yeah I got pant
that's a [ __ ] cult classic though
that's an awesome flick oh yeah made out
of nothing I do kind of feel like I can
see why he got disillusioned yeah you'd
be like [ __ ] man I can't make a good
movie with without getting [ __ ] on yeah
it's just and it's sad because it's kind
of like his curse that he makes these
movies that are like amazing but nobody
recognizes their basic and I don't like
many years like right and it's like I
can see how frustrating that would be
and how finally he was just like [ __ ]
all of you yeah came out with things
like you know what was that one
something of darkness printed Prince of
Darkness and Prince of Darkness was kind
of good but not really that was like
half again maybe you could tell it was a
carpenter movie but you could it was
busy boys very cool yeah but it just
didn't have the kind of a unified feel
the story wasn't tight enough and the
characters weren't quite compelling
enough for me but it was weird but not
good enough yeah I think a lot of it was
added and script yeah I feel like most
of his best movies and I think most
people would agree most of his best
movies were from you know late 70s early
80s yeah so after that some of those
were hit or miss like I said I haven't
seen some of his really new ones like I
haven't seen the ward or anything but I
think that thing took a lot wind out of
him because that was it's a masterpiece
and I think he has a masterpiece and
nobody recognized so yeah I can see how
that one dad that would have thought
that would have [ __ ] really burned me
up to do that yeah I'd have been really
mad [ __ ] it would be one thing if you
made a movie and you didn't really care
about it and you didn't really think it
was all that great and other people said
yeah it's not that great be like yeah I
didn't think it was me but that that's
what I mean but he made that neat boy
poured his heart and soul into it that
was like a movie that he had wanted to
make like forever because he loved the
Howard Hawks are the whole cast the
whole team keep knocked it out of the
[ __ ] park yeah and blood sweat and
tears you could tell yeah and so you
know but the same thing but so if you're
really interested in carpenter and you
haven't seen this one oh I should note
that there was a remake done in 2005
that I think it Ethan Hawke wasn't it
and maybe Laurence Fishburne I don't
know if I saw it if I did I didn't make
an impression because I don't remember
I've heard it's not very good but like I
said I can't even remember if I've seen
it or not but you know most of the time
the original is always better can I say
to that one of my favorite characters
and this I think he only has one scene
is the [ __ ] police captain you know
what like lieutenant bishop first gets
there and he's like okay well I'll tell
the campbellot everyone is like super
cranky for one thing like it is [ __ ]
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] precinct and so so
he goes in there like
- this guy and this guy is just like
what noggin is like so many [ __ ] car
thefts and yeah we're fated to stop
smilin under night and he's got like
this big [ __ ] shotgun like Roger he's
like looking for various before we
finish the retrospective I want to give
another shout out to another carpenter
flick that we briefly mentioned that's
the fog yeah don't forget about that
that's it the movie had problems it
wasn't enough horror scenes in it yeah
but it did it did have a good gothic em
ambiance to it that at the tiny there's
something that's like the atmosphere of
gonna [ __ ] me up that movie scared me
but it didn't really show enough yeah
that was the only problem with it the
rest of it though they got he got it
right the carpenter got it mostly right
it just needed it needed a couple more
violent horror scenes in it and he added
two actually went back and added some to
Jay Dukas well because originally if
yeah because originally it is supposed
it had less occasionally just supposed
to be a ghostie movie and then like when
it was done he was like man like there's
all these slasher movies coming out now
maybe I should put more gory yeah so he
went back and put more gore in it it
needed even more than the I think you're
right I think they did do I think it was
even tamer when we saw it on cable yeah
well yeah because they would have cut
along it still scared you though
especially when you were a kid
yeah we were ramping it had like a
really creepy out real good acting it
was kind of a creepy idea the fog coming
you know the something in it but ya know
that should have been that should have
been released as a slasher movie yeah
you know although I like old-school
ghost stories too but it's like I don't
know it needed about a good five or
didn't need about a good more five
minutes of [ __ ] blood and violence it
was horrible [ __ ] yeah then and then it
would have been perfect yeah I think but
you know and I have to say the fog was
remade too and that's so remakes of the
remake was only the ridge yeah well you
know where they had the fog the original
the original actually was a good kind of
sci-fi movie you have sci-fi TV you know
us have our Channel yeah been like
something you see on the Sci Fi Channel
yeah if you didn't pay for it you were
just watching it as a kid
it'd be enough but when you look at the
original you compared to the original
you'd go like nah not even close
yeah the original had a certain Gestalt
to it now I don't know if maybe because
we were in the right place the right
time right time of our lives to see it
you know we were kids seeing it back in
the context of the time I think might
have something to do with it but I don't
know I still like that movie yeah well
and you know like I said so this one if
you're into carpenter and you somehow
have not seen it it's not a horror movie
by any stretch of the imagination
Western it's like a Western action type
movie and like I said there's a lot of
setup but that's something that I kind
of like about it and sometimes like I
said if you saw it one time and you
didn't really remember anything about it
like it definitely benefits from like
second at their viewings because you
didn't see like all the threads tying
together does have a problem of the
movies of the time and that was them
trying to use these 70s gangs as hard
asses and just the way they dressed back
then and the physical fitness of the
time and they just they weren't
intimidating looking well every time I
see like a gang oriented because what we
watched another day class of 1984 or
whatever and it's like every time I see
a gang from a 70s or 80s movie I'm
always like Fame yeah yeah it's
definitely you can tell the people that
came out of drama school they're just
Sophos [ __ ] you know they're just trying
well in like like we said before it's
like they always try to make like punks
and like they always try to make like
all these gang members they're supposed
to look tough but it looks like a
costume yeah it's a it's really really
hard to avoid that right but it's like
yeah but I I had just had to laugh at
like the [ __ ] gang being called
Street Thunder yeah I'm like you imagine
if like a [ __ ] gang it's just like
even if they had guns and stuff you feel
like nah from first time I saw a cool
depiction of a gang would have been like
predator to remember the [ __ ] should
make him [ __ ] posse yeah a new posse
yeah and then the [ __ ] that then the
the Colombian cartels were fighting the
cops that was that was how they should
have looked yeah you know I mean Dade
they got that right but that was what 80
89 88 something like that it took him a
while to get it right did you make him
voodoo posse I mean that would actually
look like a gang of guys that would kill
you yeah like I said it was kind of hard
to do a gang like yeah they're trying to
do everything tough like the Warriors
were probably the worry is amplified
because I'm just like come on give me a
break but no one would be afraid of
those dude no walking around like
matching your physiology it's sucking
sleeveless weighing like a buck oh five
[ __ ] with swish in their walk and
[ __ ] man looking come the [ __ ] on man
they're coming out of dance class
they're not coming out of the hood I
mean if you're gonna do a gang it's like
they wouldn't even carry guns look at
what they did was like Clockwork Orange
that was a [ __ ] scary SK and they all
had like matching costumes but it was
what made sense that that made sense
that the Drude that in Clockwork Orange
didn't have guns everybody evidently no
guns I don't think the cops had guns
it's Europe but the Warriors I think was
supposed to be wet man in New York
Manhattan or I guess like that maybe LA
somewhere no not maybe Chicago I don't
really remember it's hard to get through
that movie today but warriors is just a
[ __ ] joke man it's still fun and they
were like supposed to be all these
badasses and bad guys oh they're
dangerous but they're not so dangerous
where they wouldn't use a gun yeah yeah
just you know they'll just kick you to
death slap you to death there's just all
slap fight so yeah I would watch that
[ __ ] Street Thunder back up out of my
neighborhood that's what I mean it
sounds like so that's when warriors was
yeah it definitely was kind of like that
yeah but yeah so assault on precinct 13
again Thank You Dominic for sending us
the really awesome steelbook edition of
that if you would like to watch it I
just noticed this morning that it is on
to be for free so you can check it out
very nice you know very nice HD
presentation just have to sit through a
sprite chance to be on this blu-ray
probably I believe it is it looked like
it looked about the same as it did when
we watched our
okay so yeah check it out if you're a
John Carpenter fan or just a fan of 70s
cinema in general